[Aplausos]
olá votar a todos
ah eu gosto de desafios e vocês a mãe
sem muito cansado estar aqui hoje
isso é fechar em grande e passarem
online que é preciso contar com duas
provas muito ciente primeiro ganha quer
favor da estrutura suficiente na área e
completa é que a fama da escravatura
ninguém olha em princípio a guarda de
outros edifícios que vão explorar uma
etiqueta da nossa roupa e vamos dizer
onu está na você tiver qualquer
expectativa é mais a mão ou melhor
dizendo quem tiver um num país europeu
handle brasil for europeu botão
agrobrasil onda não europeu de outros
países
ok o bom princípio é bom na prática é
até agora o produto para descongelar a
malta
quem é que gosta da montanha
quem gosta durante o campeonato de lá o
time está em vias de extinção
sim este é o nosso princípio nós
gostamos das coisas que estamos dos
animais que estamos do ambiente mas na
verdade estamos com 64 horário certo
como eu também não estou vendo uma coisa
que não faço todos nós falhamos em
alguma medida neste momento essa selva
indonésia arrasada por causa da produção
de óleo de palma que é exatamente o
sítio habitat natural dos hora
importante mas nós continuamos a orar o
kit kat de um café que o momento temos
que continuar de isso é fundamental o
princípio era bom
muita gente
era fanática por habitante mas a prática
continua a ser
é isso não tem tecnologia chamamos do
estudante e cognitivo ou seja quando
aquilo que eu penso nos meus los é que o
peso do mundo valoriza muito as minhas
práticas a todos fazer o visto isto o
que gera desconforto psíquico emocional
procuramos um trabalho uma casa um
companheiro procurar colmatar tudo isto
e sentir que o preenchimento havendo
fica vazio além daquelas imagens na
televisão das crianças e dos animais ea
consciência e cai outra vez
ok mas há muita gente tomou há muita
gente com tal é nova mas muitas não têm
esse elemento base 46 milhões vivem na
escravidão nós também não gostamos disto
mas continuamos a comprar roupa que vai
nascer em portugal é o quarto - foi
geral e 720 horas nosso meio 220 no menu
são passadas a trabalhar é grande média
levantar
ao contrário da e nós vemos fluida
trabalhar o nosso trabalho nosso projeto
pessoal correspondem aos nossos
princípios
qual é a nossa missão em sinal em torno
do marketing nos sonhos e sentimentos
estou a falar deste porque a criança num
projecto que eu tive no restaurante em
que estou inserida tem muito a ver com
esta questão de trabalhar em os sonhos
sentimentos
a equipa o corpo laboral o produto
neste caso comida ea comunidade se
envolveu ativamente nesse as emoções têm
esta característica são especiais muitos
dias tem som mas há uma coisa especial
dos seus humanos é que as emoções são
uma estação corporal aquilo que nós
sentimos muito físicas não é raiva
ansiedade estresse é um mergulho mas os
sentimentos são extremamente ambientais
e podem ser feitas nas consciências
antônia dá mais para estas duas coisas é
possível cumprimos a nossa missão
adicional por ser humano esta coisa
fantástica do conseg lugar nas emoções
em ruas do los pois ocultamos nosso
trabalho
era muito eu ou seja as pressões que
quem quiser se ão sobre mim e é é um tal
ordem é contra natura que achava facto o
caminho não poderia ser esse
e hoje tenho sinto que é ouvir algumas
pessoas que ganham cruzei os projetos
apareceram outros continuam a trabalhar
e eu considero um escravo do século 21
só hoje que estão atrás de um objetivo
que não seja sal é o dinheiro é e o
sucesso do inter é mais do que ser
sempre uma das coisas que mais motiva na
vida é procurasse a mais em campo e que
possa vir a ter com as pessoas porque
morei eu gosto de criar no sul tudo e eu
apesar de termos um estilista e um
bigode no fundo também é educada cursi
ao porque eu gosto em contar com
estímulos mesmo com elas com as
funcionárias mas eu gosto de dançar ou
perder ela gosta mais estar com elas do
catar sozinha as vezes que deve estar
muitas vezes sozinho não eu sempre que
posso estou até pessoal está como é que
o senhor prefeito
a lei é mesmo até nível do trato com as
outras três anos pra chegar até a
educação é que é uma coisa que muita
gente não tinha muita maneira de tratar
os outros né
e aí foram aprendendo porque chama
bastante a atenção sobre se tornaram
muito independentes porque eu também
gosto muito por isso eu acho que a
mulher deve ter deixado de ganhar e e
não precisar marido nunca vi uma vez
mais fãs
isto foi minha escolha é muito ligado ao
trabalho que faço com alimentação
produtos biológicos a 7 e com o trabalho
em parceria com o desenvolvendo já tenho
conhecido na comunidade de guimarães
isso é único autor em produção biológica
e outro exemplo é uma senhora a mais
durante uma competição
são dois exemplos práticos em como
história que consegue aliar essas duas
áreas a tim e consegui conciliar tudo
isto
todas as funções falamos do agricultor
disse que procurou será que o que é e
não aparentar do que tem
falamos do mais lento uma fábrica que
procura dotar as suas mexe trabalha só
como mexe um salário superior ao dos
homens e consegue juntar as mulheres de
independência e trabalhar com elas todas
as questões de gênero que nós temos
ouvido falar isso é extremamente
importante significa que estamos a ver
que ser a nossa retrabalho é
indispensável conseguir conciliar estas
três dimensões por outro serviço que é
que eu faço como é que eu sinto e que
optou por valley ao longo da minha vida
se corporizam num produto comida roupa o
que quer que seja aquilo que nós fazemos
que aumentou 10 nos valores que nós
defendemos está fora enquanto empresa
quer que eu sinto que eu dou eu sou
realmente plena nos projectos em que se
eu consigo vê lo à comunidade quanto às
emissões porque eu escolho vender
obviamente está ligado porque os outros
vão sentir lá fora e imediatamente eu
consegui furar a força laboral da
empresa em recife dependendo do da
posição em que estamos inseridos nessa
empresa mas que não têm este poder dar e
capacitar os trabalhadores a fazer um
trabalho e aumenta o bem comum
o meu desafio pra vocês é que o pensa em
as emoções trabalho essas invenções que
conquistem os sentimentos que nos fazem
bem e fazem aos outros e quem inventou o
empoderamento que está impulsionada
ainda temos mais uma festa nesta
engrenagem neoliberalismo então vieram
ajudar bastante
acreditamos que em dispensa é isso não
o neoliberalismo estado não ajudaram
muito menos com a quantidade de empresas
de produtos cada vez mais suja ou seja é
cada vez mais exigente para nós as
empresas sejam capazes de ter uma missão
o caíque que nós sejamos portador dessa
missão qual é o teu lucro emocional
lucro não tem uma palavra foi associada
às empresas associadas que o que se
ganha mas o que nós ganhamos quando
entramos lá seremos realmente capazes de
fazer valer os novos valores à nossa
empresa e procurar samsung vai
muito obrigado ficam costa que está o
que para nós tem ajudado espero
conseguir ter um loop no final embora
daqui online
obrigado
[Aplausos]